[Music]
we haven't done the friendzone in a
while we do have a lot of friends here
at Fox and of course chief among them is
Ainsley Earhardt of Fox & Friends you
see her every morning she's got a new
memoir out the light within me and we
want to hear what it is joins us by hey
hey Tucker thank you for having me on oh
are you kidding
always so what's it tell us about your
book so they just approached me about
writing a book about my faith because I
hear all the time you're not afraid to
share your faith so I said you know they
wanted me to write a memoir I'm like
aren't you like 70 years old when you
write a memoir I I don't have a life
story I appreciate that but I don't want
someone to think that I'm so
self-righteous that I feel like I have
so much life experience that you direct
this no more but then they said we want
you to focus on your faith and so that's
like God's saying talk about me and you
can't say no to God so I was really
excited at that point and I just I just
wrote down I have journal entries I've
write I've written a journal for years
so I a lot of my journal entries are in
here things that I've gone through the
ups and downs how I got to Fox News
Channel and mine's just the things that
inspired me my parents and I talked
about some hard times to the death of my
grandparents and I lost baby through a
miscarriage and just I've had I've had
some some downs but many more ups and so
it's just about how God's blessed my
life and I can't believe I'm this girl
from South Carolina that's on the
national news talking to Tucker Carlson
when you write a book you learn just the
process of writing teaches you what did
you learn writing this I learned that
you can do anything you want to do I
remember when my friend said let's run a
half-marathon I was like are you kidding
I can't even run around the block
without tasting blood and she said no we
can do this and let's just do more of a
it's just a walk with a little bit of a
shuffle I was like I can do that so I
ran a half marathon someone said write a
book write a children's book I'm like no
no I can't do that
I had two children's books and now I've
got this more and I'm not saying that
because I think I'm anything special I'm
not my point is you can do anything you
set your mind to
you just have to have you have to be
surrounded with good people as you know
Tucker your staffs amazing everyone that
works at Fox behind the scenes they get
they should get the glory not us because
they do all the hard work my mom said
that she got this book delivered by
Amazon today dad and I'm gonna join her
it's great to see you Trina Tamar means
is getting up very early interviewing
the president president calling it
tomorrow morning means we'll be up to
three thanks ain't it great to see you